autre manifestation a également à paris
de nombreux manifestants qui se sont
rassemblés place de la république pour
la paix en afghanistan
un appel de l'association enfants
labyanit chant et d'ailleurs qui demande
à l'europe d'agir en faveur de la paix
dans le pays et coûté son président on
sait très bien qu'on va retourner dans
les années 90 et que in guerre est
inévitable mais par contre si l'europe
intervienne politiquement si l'europe
pour entrer dans les négociations avec
les américains et aussi avec les
talibans et les autres membres de 2,2 le
temps on est sûr qu au moins on aura une
autre parce que on connaît l'europe où
on est on est en france on est dans le
pays des droits de l'homme
c'est pourquoi je demande que le
président français interviennent dans
les négociations on demande pas du tout
de de l'aide militaire ou d'intervention
militaire vraiment rentré dans les
négociations